[Musica]
mi piace sempre iniziare le mie
conferenze chiedendo al pubblico a voi
Se avete dei sogni perché dei sogni al
giorno d'oggi Secondo me se ne parla fin
troppo poco voi ne avete
il mio sogno di andare nello spazio non
è sempre il nessuno non è sempre stato
in realtà quello di andare nello spazio
da piccola ad esempio Sognavo di fare la
fioraia oppure la parrucchiera ma ho
attraversato anche poi delle fasi in cui
ho sognato di fare il chirurgo oppure
l'avvocato
ho sempre avuto Però la passione per lo
spazio e in realtà c'è un aneddoto molto
curioso di quando ero piccola della mia
infanzia
Quando frequentavo la scuola elementare
sempre verso la metà del mese di
dicembre
passavano in classe dei rappresentanti
di libri per bambini ovviamente Questi
libri erano acquistabili e io tutti gli
anni chiedevo ai miei genitori se
potevano acquistarmi appunto questi
Questi libri sulla scienza e sullo
spazio ovviamente ricavato veniva Donato
in beneficenza poi che facevo una quando
avevo le ore di supplenza Ad esempio in
classe passiamo tutte queste ore a
trascrivere tutto ciò che era scritto
all'interno di questi libri e la stessa
cosa la facevo a casa
ma riparliamo un attimo del mio sogno il
mio sogno in realtà di andare nello
spazio l'ho indossato per la prima volta
nel 2014 quando ero chiuso nella mia
cameretta con gli occhi fissi ma proprio
fissi sullo schermo del mio computer e
guardavo Samantha cristoforetti lasciare
la terra per andare nello spazio
esattamente il 10 novembre 2014 è
iniziata anche la mia corsa verso lo
spazio che in qualche modo ho raggiunta
da aprile 2022
Ma cosa mi ha portato in realtà ad
arrivare al centro addestramento
Astronauti analoghi in Polonia dopo aver
frequentato il liceo scientifico
mi sono iscritta ad ingegneria
aerospaziale
convintissima che avrebbe alimentato
immensamente questa mia passione per lo
spazio che avrai trovato persone come me
che tutti i giorni avremmo parlato di
Astronauti di aerei Però qualcosa più
passava il tempo passavano i mesi è
qualcosa dentro di me stava cambiando ad
aprire fino a quando ad aprile 2017 è
cresciuta Prima piano piano e poi
prepotentemente dentro di me la
consapevolezza che quella facoltà che io
avevo scelto in realtà con tantissimo
amore non era come l'aveva immaginata
non era ciò che dice ciò che desideravo
non mi piaceva io volevo sporcarmi le
mani in laboratorio
desideravo fare spazio ma lì di spazio
non ce n'era e in più non c'era neanche
spazio per Liliana
così mi sono iscritta alla facoltà di
Scienze Naturali a Bologna indirizzo
astrobiologia l'astrobiologia la ricerca
di vita nell'universo e finalmente ho
realizzato iniziato a realizzare i miei
sogni di toccare sempre più vicino e
essere sempre più vicina allo spazio
quando lasciate l'università di
ingegneria aerospaziale in realtà alcuni
miei colleghi di corso mi dissero che
avevo fallito io a 19 anni mi sono
sentita dire dai miei colleghi di corso
e anche amici che avevo fallito secondo
loro io ero una fallita agli occhi del
mondo perché non ce l'avevo fatta non
ero riuscita a laurearmi in ingegneria
ero sbagliata in realtà più mi dicevano
queste cose più era carburante le loro
parole erano carburante per la mia
consapevolezza di chi ero per capire che
chi volevo diventare
come ho affrontato in realtà questo i
fallimenti secondo loro ho sempre visto
i fallimenti come un qualcosa che in
realtà non insegnano niente niente in
positivo niente negativo ma io penso che
da qualsiasi esperienza si riesca a
trarre qualsiasi informazione un
insegnamento sia positivo che negativo
di conseguenza io come potevo aver
fallito quell'esperienza a me stava
insegnando più di qualsiasi altra cosa
prima nella vita
Facciamo un passo indietro lo sapevate
che gli astronauti delle missioni Apollo
si sono addestrati su terreni terrestri
o meglio era una realtà dei campi di
patate
avete sentito campi di patate creati
appositamente attraverso delle
esplosioni per simulare il suolo lunare
quindi terreno lunare Ovviamente per
simulare quindi crateri le discese e
anche gli ostacoli ovviamente E
giustamente qualcuno di voi o qualcuna
si potrebbe chiedere ma perché hanno
bombardato un campo di patate la
risposta in realtà è molto più facile di
quanto si possa pensare
la vediamo tra un attimo però perché
come noi andiamo in realtà a scuola
guida per imparare a guidare la macchina
per prendere la patente per la macchina
gli astronauti delle missioni Apollo
sono andati alla scuola guida per
prendere appunto la patente per pilotare
Rover lunari
immaginiamo adesso
di fare di partire per un viaggio
spaziale Quali sono secondo voi
provate magari a rispondere dentro di
voi i problemi o le difficoltà che si
possono trovare in un Viaggio Spaziale
di lunga durata Io ne ho pensati quattro
in realtà che secondo me sono i più
importanti poi sicuramente l'isolamento
siamo lontani da tutti quanti siamo soli
non niente più vicino a noi se non
Ovviamente i nostri compagni di missione
il confinamento siamo perennemente
confinati che sia una navicella che sia
la nostra tuta o che sia l'habitat in
cui vivremo sulla Luna su Marte siamo
confinati noi non siamo abituati in
realtà essere confinati siamo piuttosto
liberi un ambiente ostile per l'essere
umano quando l'essere umano arriva sulla
luna non c'è nessuno ad aspettarlo con
le bandierine e i fuochi d'artificio
Anzi ci dà dei forti e chiari segnali
che li È tutto difficile per noi
un'altra caratteristica
l'impossibilità di ricevere
approfondimenti quante volte noi ci
capita abbiamo voglia di insalata di
qualsiasi tipo di cosa ci viene in mente
possiamo uscire andarla a comprare se si
ha nello spazio Ovviamente non è così
semplice se ci viene voglia di insalata
dobbiamo accontentarci probabilmente del
cibo in scatola che abbiamo
queste simulazioni sulla terra Quindi
hanno proprio lo scopo di studiare e
provare a capire come affrontare queste
problematiche e prendono il nome
dimissioni analoghe le stesse che poi
hanno fatto gli astronauti delle
missioni Apollo e coloro che le
effettuano che quindi effettuano queste
missioni analoghe sono chiamati
Astronauti analoghi come me
facciamo insieme una derivazione
cambiamo in realtà proprio argomento
immaginiamo tutti quanti assieme domani
che domani ognuno di noi sarà sottoposto
a un test non lo fa un compito un
compito a crocette non abbiamo la più
pallida idea di che cosa ci chiederà
questo test non sappiamo Quale sarà il
punteggio minimo per superarlo non
sappiamo niente del test di domani
ovviamente dobbiamo andarci per forza
non possiamo rifiutarci
Però proviamo a immaginare la situazione
opposta invece domani sempre ognuno di
noi avrà un test sappiamo tutto di
questo test sappiamo l'argomento
sappiamo che sarà Crocette sappiamo
qualsiasi cosa secondo voi in quale
situazione vi sentite Cioè voi in che
situazione vi sentite più sicuri penso
la seconda cioè io perlomeno mi sentirei
estremamente sicura nella seconda
opzione saprei tutto quanto del test di
domani potrai fare la mia miglior
performance potrai ottenere il miglior
risultato
Ecco perché nella nuova era spaziale è
nata la figura dell'astronauta analogo
quindi chi sono questi Astronauti
analoghi gli astronauti analoghi sono
delle persone che simulano sulla terra
possibile missioni spaziali sulla luna
oppure su Marte come abbiamo visto prima
l'addestramento a terra per gli
astronauti delle missioni Apollo è stato
essenziale ed è tutt'oggi questo
addestramento a terra è essenziale per i
futuri Astronauti che raggiungeranno lo
spazio in questo caso ovviamente la
stazione spaziale internazionale Ma è
ancora più importante questo
addestramento a terra per i futuri
Astronauti che raggiungeranno la Luna o
Marte
Ma cosa di cosa abbiamo bisogno per
tornare sulla luna Abbiamo sicuramente
bisogno di conoscenza di sperimentazione
e di test e tanti test abbiamo bisogno
di sapere perfettamente come la mente
umana reagisce ad un isolamento forzato
di settimana se non mesi se non anni se
parliamo di Marte esattamente così uno
dei fattori più importanti di un Viaggio
Spaziale è sicuramente un fattore
psicologico ed ecco come abbiamo visto
prima l'isolamento oppure il
confinamento come reagisce l'essere
umano abituata a vivere in una società a
stretto contatto con i suoi simili a
stretto contatto con le persone a cui
vuole bene a ritrovarsi
Paradossalmente catapultato in una
realtà completamente differente dove
isolato dove non può avere costanti
contatti istantanei con la famiglia con
gli amici dove non ha la natura
circondarlo
gli animali non si vedono nessuno ma
l'unico animale che si può vedere sono i
nostri compagni di missione Come ci si
sentirebbe a essere circondati
dall'immensità dell'universo
così dopo anni di duro lavoro in realtà
sono riuscita ad arrivare su quella che
io chiamo la mia luna che per sette
giorni è stata la mia casa Siamo in
Polonia Aprile 2022 Siamo al confine con
l'Ucraina è appena scoppiata la guerra e
noi 5 saremo isolati senza nessuna
comunicazione con famiglie o amici non
sarà possibile comunicare con nessuno
l'energia che abbiamo per ricaricare i
nostri telefoni oppure i nostri computer
o per far funzionare in realtà tutta
quanta la strumentazione
è limitata Però possiamo pedalare sulla
cyclette per produrla non abbiamo acqua
Per lavarci ma abbiamo lì in realtà in
un angolo a fissarci 12 bottiglie
d'acqua ciascuno per 12 giorni con le
quali dovremmo cucinare lavarci i denti
e fare gli esperimenti ovviamente anche
per bere non vedremo sorgere il sole o
tramontare la luna non vedremo nel sole
dell'una non vedremo più le stelle non
sapremo neanche in realtà che ore
saranno e le nostre giornate potrebbero
durare 36 ore ma anche 12
potremmo stare per andare a dormire dopo
una giornata estenuante di 20 ore
quando il controllo missione ci avvisa
che in realtà noi a dormire Non possiamo
andarci che è di nuovo mattina e
dobbiamo fare la colazione
se è sconosciuti Nel nostro caso della
nostra missione in realtà 5
che si sono dati per mesi un
appuntamento fisso ogni lunedì per
organizzare online tutta quanta la
missione che si ritrovano a convivere e
a volte sopravvivere in un ambiente così
ostile difficile caotico piccolo e
perennemente illuminato per sette giorni
tante caratteristiche simili a quelle di
una futura missione sulla luna per una
settimana come ho già detto siamo stati
sottoposti a test soprattutto
psicologici dal primo momento in cui si
metteva il piede sotto dal letto fino a
quando andavamo a dormire i nostri corpi
sono stati portati allo stremo ad
esempio attraverso la deprivazione del
sonno quanti di noi Magari è successo
che hanno dormito 2/3 ore per notte la
mattina Erano devastati Ecco provate ad
immaginarlo per farlo per una settimana
oppure
siamo stati sottoposti a temperature
estreme abbiamo fatto un esperimento in
cui siamo stati sottoposti per tre
minuti all'incirca una temperatura prima
di meno 60 gradi centigradi e poi meno
120 gradi tutte condizioni estreme
condizioni che ricordano condizioni
nuovamente che abbiamo nello spazio come
reagisce ve lo chiedo un'altra volta
Secondo voi l'essere umano abituato
quindi a vivere in una comunità a
contatto con le persone a contatto con
la natura che dà per scontata tutto ciò
che lo circonda probabilmente il profumo
dell'erba gli animali che si vedono
all'immensità ritrovarsi Nell'immensità
dell'universo